foreign
in Seattle Jen's been waiting forever
what's up Jen
hi Dr John I'm so excited I'm doing
really great how are you I'm good so
you've got to hear you got to hear how
bad I am at making ads and all the stuff
you got to hear all the sausage made so
way to go thanks for I I kept thinking
it's a really fun perspective at some
point you're just gonna be like I I'm
I'm out I hang up hey but here's the
thing I always say on this show like I'm
not very good at this and I know it
sounds like I'm being self-deprecating
but you got to hear like oh you're not
that good at this all right you got to
hear it which is kind of awesome the
other night I was in a uh um
uh this band under oath came I missed
them when they were popular 15 years ago
and so I went to the show it was sold
out it was Mayhem and this guy stops me
in the mosh pit and he's like oh you're
for real you actually go to these shows
and I was like yeah did you think I
didn't grow this evidently people
thought I had this big
anyway so you can see I'm not that good
at the radio Jen so I'm glad that you
you've hung in there with us so what's
up what's going on
okay
um so my husband and I have been
together since we were 16. we are both
34 now gross was it like Dawson's Creek
like I don't want to wait how'd y'all
meet no in high school well in Junior
High
um uh and so yeah he was he came into my
school in eighth grade and we were sort
of like just saw each other you know how
awkward Middle School junior high is and
but the new boy came and you were like
like sites lasered in just right off the
bat he was really nice to his little
sister who that that really made me fall
in love with him did you have braces
what's that did you have braces I did oh
so great like that's so amazing I always
wanted like a childhood Crush that
became my lifelong love didn't work out
that way for me but congratulations okay
so it's not always as cute as you would
think I was gonna say this may be a
disaster so I'm sorry if I'm just
setting you up here but all right go
ahead
so we've been together since we were 16
we're both 34 now
um we've been married for 12 years this
year we have three little kids and I
don't know why but so there's never been
any infidelity any any issues we've
never cheated neither of us are cheaters
my husband has very high moral standards
specifically with our relationship and
just in his life in general but
for some reason I've always felt really
insecure when he's around other women
and it just it's really been coming to a
head recently for some reason
um I mean admittedly uh I don't have
fantastic self-worth I grew up with an
alcoholic father and a narcissistic
mother and I you know I've been really
digging into that therapy Jim I'm
laughing not because
that was incredible that was incredible
incredible
um self-awareness you know yes yes it's
it's hey that is not this country's
strong suit so well done well done yeah
um
so if if you can honestly rule out
infidelity and so when somebody comes
and says this to me the first thing I
always say is what does your gut tell
you and if you can say my gut tells me
he's a great guy like there's not some
I'm not overriding some innate signal
that my body's picking up on the
Universe
um
then the issue is clearly and I say this
with all love and respect it's nothing
to do with him it says everything to do
with you
yes right I can say with a thousand
percent like I would be completely and
utterly shocked if I ever found out
anything okay like I I can really
confidently say yeah so tell me what is
it gonna sound so cheese-bally tell me
what your body does
when he is coming home from work and
he's and you're like what are you doing
like well my last meetings with so and
so and so and so and she's beautiful
what does your body do
oh uh well I
I can feel the physical symptoms of the
anxiety like my body gets really shaky
and my heart starts racing and all the
thoughts start going that I'm trying to
just keep the lid on that jar always
super good at keeping the lid yeah what
are the thoughts
she's you know I'm a stay at home I run
our our business we run our business
together actually and so I run our
business and and I've been to stay at
home mom my oldest is going to be 10
this year and I just don't put in the
effort I used to because I'm here all
the time and so um what does that mean
what does that mean you know put in the
effort and what and looking pretty in
you know okay yeah to my parents and so
I'm like okay well she's prettier than
me and she probably doesn't have as many
so she's probably easier going than I am
and you know why wouldn't he you know
even entertain the idea because that's a
you know an easier path like she's nice
and she's pretty and she's you know
successful and has these Ambitions and
all this stuff and it just really starts
setting in even though I know that's not
how he feels I can't stop those thoughts
it's insane
um it's not insane
the good news is your body's working
great
the bad news is it's running an old
script
okay
um
one point of clarification is there a
particular person you've zeroed in on or
is this women Universal
mostly universal
um so we
so my husband's an electrician we have
our own business and we just hired we're
a small we're baby business bill but we
just hired our first employee and she's
a trainee and it's a woman which for the
trades is not super common
um and she's fantastic I never I was a
part of the hiring process she was the
best candidate and I saw it as an
opportunity for growth for me because
I've never I I've always hated this in
our entire relationship so I'm like you
know what I don't want to shortchange
our business and I want to grow
she's great I don't get any weird vibes
from her like I'm gonna you know she's
not gonna Hand That Rocks the Cradle me
at least I don't that's not the vibe I
get you know and so
um
yeah she's I mean she's tall and she's
beautiful and she has a great attitude
and she's being taught by him which my
husband is a teacher like he loves he
loves teaching and so like she's out
there with him day in Day Out hours on
end in the same truck working side by
side with him and so right now
there hasn't really been a specific
person before then it's just kind of a
general sense and now it's definitely
amped up and I'm just trying to work
through it okay
um all right a couple of things here
we're gonna start all the way back and
then we're gonna land to right now okay
okay
um I'm gonna make myself a quick note
here here all right so
the child of an alcoholic
and the child of a narcissist
that is somebody surrounded by two
people
who are using the child as their point
of gravity
which means everything you accomplish
not love because it's it's not what
you're getting
but you accomplish stability through
performance
through what you can do for them
right
yeah
and that carries all the way through
your life and so when you see yourself
as a performer
and then life happens you gain some
weight you are chasing 15 kids around a
farm you're running out of business just
life happens
um
you begin the same judgment metrics
are what you apply regardless of the
situation
because there's still a six-year-old
little girl saying God what is so
beautiful about that bottle
that that makes it prettier than me
what is it about me
that my mom keeps using me as a
scorecard for how well she's doing in
the world why is it my job to make sure
she's regulated I I right and so yeah
you take that scorecard because your mom
and dad were supposed to be the only two
people on the planet
that didn't do that and they did our
teachers do it our coaches do it our
friends do it that's life our bosses do
it that's life
but not Mom and Dad not them two
yeah
and they said if you're going to be in
relationship with us this is how you're
going to dance and you took that card
and you tattooed it on your heart and
now you're a mom you're a business owner
you're a wife you're a best friend and
you're trying to use that same that same
card
so here I'm trying to think of like a
non-lame example but um
um
let me think of like a baseball player
um I'll use a baseball player for my
childhood Craig Biggio came in he was a
catcher but he's really really fast
coming in when I was a little kid and he
played for the Astros and so in a couple
of years they moved him from being a
catcher to be in a second baseman to
preserve his legs
and then he played forever and over the
course of history he got stronger and he
got his I call it his dad's strength his
start the lawnmower with one pole and he
stopped being judged on how fast he was
he started being judged on how he could
get clutch hits how he never missed
Ground balls how he was a great teammate
and then as even the physical it became
he's the great he's a clubhouse leader
we're going to keep him on a few more
years even though his skills have
diminished because he's leading these
young folks
and so the metric by which they judged
him continued to change and evolve with
him
because that it makes rational sense but
kids who grew up in traumatic households
stamped themselves with one scorecard
okay so you are gonna have to learn to
teach yourself and you're gonna have to
be honest and open with your husband and
teach him
I've got to learn a new way of of
um seeing myself in the world
and it used to be as a performer and
here's what's going to be hard you've
half of his life you've been a performer
too
right and that means you may have agreed
to things in the bedroom you weren't
super down with but you want to be you
want to be the cool wife and you may be
doing things with kids that you don't
really love but he wants you to do it
and so it's like okay we'll just it's
gonna change the dynamic of your house
as you begin to develop autonomy and say
here's what I want here's what I need
that's why both of you are gonna have to
commit to okay the marriages we knew it
we're gonna put a period at the end of
that it got us this far it's it can't it
can't move forward or it's going to
implode because I can't continue to
score myself with these same metrics
that I used when I was seven and that my
mom and dad who were sick used on me
to be the wife and the mother and the
business owner that we need to be moving
forward does this make sense
yeah okay
and
I think this is me it's going to be very
unpopular with the internet crowd so do
not read the YouTube comments actually
you can read them because you're gonna
be about me
I do think
um y'all are playing with fire
okay I think there's something to be
said for some accountability
or let me put it this way I would not be
comfortable
hiring a single female to drive around
with me for nine hours a day just us two
working side by side for the future for
a hundred different reasons
and I trust myself
right I don't know what she's gonna say
I don't know what someone's gonna accuse
us of I don't know what impact this is
going to have on my wife I don't know if
this is going to impact it's gonna have
on my business
I don't know any of those factors and I
get that there's um in an eight
um I don't call it sexism but I I don't
want to ever want gender to I want to
hire the best person for the job right
so it may be that in this season we're
gonna hire two people
we're gonna hire two people
and it's going to cost us a little more
money and we're it but it's going to be
worth it in the in the long long run
and if we take a hit for a couple of
years and train them up right and how
we're going to take care of customers
and the kind of quality of work we do
then it's going to expand your employee
base
but I think there's a both and here okay
I want you to know you're not insane
okay nobody nobody well that's not true
very very very few happily married
people
wake up one day and they're like I'm
gonna go have an affair this is not what
happens the number one reason people
have an affair is access
just happens
and so it's not something it's it's a
and and it's stunning how many people
have great marriages and this thing
happens right and so it's it's not like
somebody's fault or it's because of this
or because that's a Hollywood reality is
like it it just it just happened so I
think there's something to be said for
sitting back and being smart
and or
yeah I'll leave that to you and your
husband and your business to figure that
out but in yours in my situation at my
house I would hire two people even if I
couldn't afford it I would figure out
how to hire two and that's for as much
for her protection as it is for
um for for him for your marriage for
everybody
I just think there's a wisdom there
um and in a rush to and I think it's a
good rush in a rush for equality we've
sometimes thrown out common sense
and I wish that wasn't the case but
that's just reality
um so I tell you that all that to tell
you a couple of things number one
continue to see your counselor because
you got to deal with the childhood stuff
it's real and it's heavy and it's legit
okay I want you to know you're not nuts
yeah the second thing is
um I want you to begin to feel your body
as it begins to take off on you
and I want you to and this is going to
be a pain if you will do this for one
month two months maybe four months if
you will continue to do this to write
down every time it takes off on you
please take the time to write it down
it's gonna be a pain in the butt
but it's the way you're going to teach
yourself to create some space between
your body taken off on you and
those thoughts that come next you got to
start challenging those thoughts the
third thing is I want you and your
husband to have a some sort of retreat
where y'all can say okay we're going to
reimagine our marriage where we want to
look like we got two kids we got a small
business we're trying to make these
things work here we are
we've done six months here in this new
job I'm not comfortable with this I'm
super comfortable with this I just feel
like we're setting our family up for a
weird thing here or a weird thing there
um
whatever's going on in the world so
and just so you know my wife and I did
this with my job we're six months into a
new job you're on the road a lot you're
traveling you've got these weird writing
hours now you're riding at 4am and at
two in the morning
so five six months in how is everything
two years in how is everything and in
next week I think or the week after
we're doing it again like we are now I
just hit send out another manuscript
okay we gotta recalibrate this thing
because our marriage is different now
again so that's an ongoing conversation
that needs to happen needs to happen and
you can ask some of those questions like
what do you need from me in this season
and let him be honest with you about
what he needs and then you can say okay
here's a list not one that I'm imagining
not a performance schedule that I'm
supposed to be keeping up with but he
told me exactly what he needs from me
and I want you to be honest honest
honest and tell him here's what I need
from you here's what I need from you
I don't know that you can do this
without a family counselor without a
marriage counselor and I would I think
that would be super good use of your
time and of your money and you're worth
all of it all of it all of it stay on
the line I'm going to send you a copy of
own your past change your future in fact
I'm gonna send you two and you and your
husband can both read it together
um I think that would be fantastic for
both of you to give give each of you a
common language as you head into this
new season I think that'd be awesome
um thank you so much for being brave
thank you so much for the call your
body's working as it should and
it's trying to keep you safe and it's
trying to run an old script and what it
used to keep you safe the way it used to
keep you safe it's gonna mess things up
moving forward so let's get a new script
moving forward I'm so grateful for you
Jen